moi je viens du Sud-Est j'habite à
j'habite à Sanary
scénariste sur mer je suis du golf de
terre blanche
j'ai commencé le golf vers les 7-8 ans
je suis allé rentrer sport études à
Antibes au pôle espoir à l'âge de 15 ans
pendant 2 ans après je suis anthropole
France ça va faire ma sixième année là
que je suis avec la Fédération j'ai fait
j'ai eu ma première sélection équipe de
France à 15 ans et là ça s'enchaîne
comme il faut jusque jusqu'à mon passage
proche j'espère
[Musique]
j'avais de la famille qui joue au golf
mon père joue au golf ma sœur jouer au
golf donc c'était facile entre
guillemets d'y aller et après bah j'ai
pris goût j'avais des potes qui jouent
au golf je m'amusais bien
mes potes à moi sont partis au Pôle
Espoir un an plus que moi donc j'avais
envie de les rejoindre et du coup je me
suis mis un peu plus sérieusement et
voilà
j'ai encore une année en amateur où je
vais essayer de jouer beaucoup de gros
tournois amateur et
pas mal d'invitations sur Challenge Tour
j'espère
[Musique]